[Musica]
ho 17 anni io ho scoperto cosa fossero i
diritti umani ho scoperto cosa volesse
dire sentirsene privati e sentirsi
vulnerabili a 17 anni infatti ho vissuto
il terremoto dell'aquila e per qualche
giorno dopo il 6 aprile 2009
non avevo altro se non il diritto ad
essere soccorsa anche se non sempre
secondo i miei bisogni in quei giorni si
sono create delle comunità all'interno
della comunità dei micro mondi ognuno
portava avanti la causa del gruppo al
quale apparteneva e le differenze tra i
diversi micromondi erano ben visibili
poi si è creata un'altra comunità una
bolla che ci ha circondato ovvero
l'aiuto proveniente dall'esterno infatti
in quei giorni nella mia città si sono
riversate migliaia di persone
professionisti e volontari tutti con un
unico nobile obiettivo quello di aiutare
degli sconosciuti in difficoltà degli
sconosciuti
ecco nello stesso momento si è andata a
delineare una differenza uno squilibrio
tra chi soccorreva e chiara soccorso una
strana co dipendenza che poi ho rivisto
infinite volte durante le mie esperienze
di lavoro nel suo globale in paesi dove
chi soccorre si sente investito del
diritto di parlare per chi ha soccorso e
quest'ultimo lo legittima tacitamente di
fatto andando a ridare qualcosa indietro
al soccorritore perché comunque dobbiamo
ricordare che anche aiutare è una
manifestazione del potere il potere può
assumere diverse forme e credo che al
giorno d'oggi ci rendiamo ancora troppo
poco conto dell'importanza del potere
della comunicazione soprattutto in
alcuni ambiti i moderni concetti di
povertà sviluppo paesi in via di
sviluppo sono stati plasmati durante gli
anni 80 un periodo di forti crisi
globali caratterizzati da una grande
presenza mediatica e da una
strumentalizzazione politica dell'aiuto
umanitario
il caso dell'etiopia diventa un esempio
lampante di una crisi locale e di una
campagna di sensibilizzazione portata
avanti su scala globale dai media e da
artisti di grandissima fama che
organizzano il primo concerto trasmesso
internazionalmente in televisione ovvero
il live aid con l'unico obiettivo di
salvare l'africa a sfamare l'africa
ecco questo oltre a creare i primi
stereotipi sul continente africano
inteso come continente povero in realtà
porta la sofferenza umana di paesi molto
lontani nella casa di tutti noi
la porta sotto gli occhi di tutti la dà
in pasto ad un ampio pubblico senza però
fornire gli strumenti per comprendere le
cause alla base di questa crisi di
queste crisi ecco il problema è che in
quei giorni ci si chiede per quale
motivo muore così tanta gente di fame in
etiopia ma perché l'etiopia è un paese
sfortunato è un paese sottosviluppato è
un paese africano
i concetti orribili in realtà il
discorso è che ci sono delle
implicazioni geopolitiche connesse alla
decolonizzazione alla guerra fredda ma
sono troppo complesse per essere
standardizzate trasformate in slogan
utilizzare degli stereotipi ci avvicina
ad un problema però quello che rischiamo
e che lo analizziamo solo da un punto di
vista superficiale
l'altro problema l'altro effetto
collaterale è che ci ammaliamo di quella
che si chiama la sindrome dello
spettatore della sofferenza siamo tutti
spettatori della sofferenza lo
spettatore della sofferenza nel sicuro
della propria casa e attraverso uno
schermo assiste a delle immagini
devastanti
strazianti di povertà freddo fame guerre
bombe morte paesi però lontani e viene
bombardato talmente tanto di queste
immagini che si sente sopraffatto si
sente esausto e come se guardasse lo
stesso film per l'ennesima volta sa già
come comincerà e come andrà a finire
e si sente quasi infastidito infatti ci
siamo sentiti tutti quasi infastidito
davanti alle pubblicità delle grandi
organizzazioni umanitarie che ci
mostrano il piccolo niro che muore di
fame in kenya ha coperto di mosche
spogliato della sua dignità che cosa
possiamo farci niente
oppure al contrario la comunicazione
umanitaria ci da uno strano senso di
onnipotenza perché fornisce delle
risposte molto semplici ha dei problemi
molto complessi che tra l'altro ci fanno
sentire inutili con 12 centesimi al
giorno puoi salvare la vita di un
bambino e mali per te 12 centesimi non
sono nulla per lui la vita
ed ecco che andiamo a svalutare
l'importanza dell'aiuto umanitario con
12 centesimi non si offre un supporto di
un certo livello ad una popolazione in
difficoltà e contemporaneamente ci
convinciamo del fatto che basta poco per
fare tanto e non c'è niente di più
sbagliato perché così noi diamo un
valore diverso minore alla sofferenza
degli altri e noi stessi viviamo
nell'illusione egocentrica
io stessa sono partita per l'india per
la prima volta a 19 anni avevo la testa
piena di preconcetti sulla povertà lo
sviluppo e mi sentivo sopraffatta per la
maggior parte del tempo
provavo anche un enorme senso di colpa
ovviamente nel sentirmi una privilegiata
e mi sembrava di appropriarmi della
sofferenza di altri stanno male è
commossa da questo senso di colpa
costante cercavo di aiutare in maniera
indiscriminata commettendo solo errori
infatti regalare dei soldi ad un bambino
di 7 anni che ti dice di vivere per
strada non lo aiutano gli cambia la vita
anzi lo convince del fatto che se vuole
sopravvivere non deve ambire a niente di
meglio troverà sempre qualcuno che gli
darà dei soldi e magari uno europeo per
cui 12 centesimi non sono nulla
ecco questo è un grandissimo problema
anche perché spesso si parte per fare
volontariato in paesi in via di sviluppo
o si va a lavorare per organizzazione in
paesi in via di sviluppo senza avere le
competenze e questo non fortifica nella
comunità nello organizzazione infatti
quando e noi aiutiamo qualcuno la prima
cosa che dovremmo chiederci sa di cosa è
bisogno tu e solo dopo cosa posso fare
io non il contrario perché aiutare vuol
dire risponde ad un bisogno specifico
non calare qualcosa dall'alto
io questo l'ho imparato sbagliando
osservando gli altri sbagliare infatti
cos'è che mette in dubbio le nostre
convinzioni
l'esperienza inaspettata oppure l'errore
ci mette in crisi ci mette in
discussione
noi qui pensiamo di avere siamo convinti
di avere abbastanza strumenti per
informarci abbiamo selezionato una serie
di canali e l'autore l'articolo di
giornale anche il contesto culturale al
quale apparteniamo e siamo convinti per
la maggior parte del tempo di avere
ragione perché abbiamo selezionato le
informazioni giuste
questo ovviamente non è possibile noi
non possiamo avere sempre ragione c'è
sempre spazio per spingere la nostra
zona di confort un po più in là e per
apprendere qualcosa di nuovo per entrare
in crisi io sono stata beneficiaria di
un intervento di emergenza per diverse
settimane e ho imparato qualcosa che non
avrai assolutamente potuto apprendere
dallo studio della teoria poi mi sono
spostata sul campo quindi passando dall
altro lato e ho capito quali fossero le
delicatissime
implicazioni che si nascondono dietro
questo rapporto questo binomio
soccorritore beneficiario è molto
difficile avere un rapporto equilibrato
quando si rivestono dei ruoli che sono
dettati dal contesto politico sociale
geografico economico e spesso si parte
anche da un altro un presupposto
sbagliato ovvero che chi è in uno stato
di enorme necessità di essere aiutato
accetterà qualsiasi forma di aiuto ma
questo non è vero
anzi
chi è in uno stato di grande necessità
deve volere il meglio perché una
catastrofe non elimina la dignità di un
essere umano anzi la rafforza se vengo
colpita da una guerra se vivo in uno
stato di grande povertà se perdo la casa
in un terremoto io non devo
accontentarmi delle briciole io devo
volere il meglio per me per la mia
famiglia per la mia comunità e quindi
chiesto il campo chi aiuta deve dare il
meglio deve dare quello che darebbe a se
stesso alla sua famiglia alla sua
comunità
se in siria c'è la guerra e non esistono
scuole questo non mi giustifica nel
costruire una struttura fatiscente
perché tanto è meglio di niente un
ragazzo che scappa dal male o
dall'afghanistan e arriva in europa non
deve accontentarsi di vivere in un
hotspot infernale perché tanto è meglio
di niente se io perdo la casa in un
terremoto non devo accontentarmi di
vivere in una tenda per settimane perché
tanto è meglio di niente
il concetto del è meglio di niente
questi come il basta poco per fare tanto
deve scomparire dal panorama dell'aiuto
locale ed internazionale e noi abbiamo
il dovere di interrompere questo
meccanismo di dire di no e ci dobbiamo
mettere in testa che aiutare è difficile
richiede tempo e richiede competenze
il concetto di compassione il concetto
il dovere morale connesso alleviare le
sofferenze altrui è passato negli ultimi
due secoli da una dimensione privata
quindi io aiuto the ad una dimensione
internazionale pubblica quindi uno stato
aiuta un altro stato
un'organizzazione umanitaria aiuta una
comunità e di fatto ha preso delle
connotazioni politiche creando nuove
categorie nuovi doveri nuovi diritti i
diritti infatti sono un concetto
artificiale non sono presenti in natura
sono qualcosa che è stato sintetizzato e
noi dobbiamo renderci conto che la
nostra società evolve e muta e nel 2050
esisteranno nuovi diritti
nonostante quelli fondamentali
ovviamente siano inviolabili ecco chi ha
sintetizzato i diritti umani è partito
dal presupposto per cui nonostante le
differenti architetture culturali che
caratterizzano le nostre società ci sia
un filo rosso un qualcosa che ci lega
una bellezza vulnerabile una verità la
libertà la libertà di vivere
dignitosamente
che ha un diritto negato alla maggior
parte della popolazione mondiale
proprio perché è profondamente connesso
con dei sistemi politici che poggiano i
propri meccanismi sud e proprio che
poggiano i propri equilibri sud e
meccanismi che sono folli che sono
crudeli e che perpetuano la
disuguaglianza la povertà alla guerra ed
è per questo che noi non possiamo
delegare il rispetto dei diritti umani a
quegli stati che li calpestano per i
diritti umani dobbiamo lottare tutti ma
non in un'ottica egoista ovvero pensando
che domani potrebbe succedere a noi
perché tanto la maggior parte di noi non
succederà mai noi dobbiamo lottare per i
diritti umani perché sono universali
altrimenti come disse un pioniere del
settore sarebbero solo il privilegio di
pochi e allora perché non lo schiavo
noi lottiamo perché ci sentiamo
schiacciati perché ci sentiamo inutili
per via della comunicazione umanitaria e
perché pensiamo che il problema è
lontano da casa nostra quindi non ci
riguarda questo ovviamente non è vero
però far parte di quella bolla che ha
circondato l'aquila nel 2009 è un
privilegio è il privilegio di avere gli
strumenti di essere nella posizione di
migliorare la vita a qualcuno che è in
difficoltà e quindi come tale va
esercitato noi dobbiamo costruire la
nostra coscienza critica
quotidianamente dobbiamo utilizzare
tutti gli strumenti a disposizione per
lottare per noi stessi e per gli altri
l'adoc ha sia uno di quegli strumenti la
bocca sia un termine inglese che deriva
dal verbo to madre kate che vuol dire
farsi promotore delle cause degli altri
come dire che io ho gli strumenti tu hai
il problema e insieme ai cooperiamo
affinché gli risolva il problema tuo e
della tua comunità a un livello politico
a livello sistemico ovviamente per fare
avvocati ci vuole una grandissima
passione e soprattutto bisogna avere ben
chiari gli obiettivi che si vogliono
raggiungere
questa sono io durante la mia prima
campagna di advocacy a 19 anni
come potete vedere il mio strumento di
battaglia è una carriola la carriola per
fare giardinaggio
il bello della droga si infatti è che
trasforma ogni oggetto in uno strumento
e ogni strumento in una potenziale
campagna di sensibilizzazione
noi all'epoca c'eravamo messi in testa
di svuotare la città dell'aquila dalle
macerie ovviamente un'idea folle ma
l'obiettivo era quello di riportare
attenzione mediatica su un problema che
lentamente stava passando in secondo
piano e noi volevamo dire che c'eravamo
e che avremmo lottato per
quell'obiettivo
questo in realtà è anche un esempio per
dire che la maggior parte di noi può
lottare per i propri diritti la maggior
parte di noi non deve fare uno sforzo
eccessivo per essere compreso e per
essere rispettato o meglio può ci
saranno sicuramente degli ostacoli degli
impedimenti ma può utilizzare la propria
voce è per questo che la droga sia
importante perché la maggior parte della
popolazione mondiale questo diritto non
ce l'ha non ha il diritto di esercitare
la propria voce di farsi ascoltare
quindi la bocca si è importante per chi
non ha questi diritti per chi non ha
quella voce è quello che ci permette di
ricreare un ponte tra noi soccorritori e
i beneficiari e ci permette di chiedere
a loro di esprimere i loro bisogni
quindi il discorso qui è che una tesi
che non viene accettata da tutti ma il
mondo sta cambiando e le lotte sono
cambiate rispetto agli anni 70 quando
l'apoteosi dell'aiuto umanitario era
raffigurata dall'operatore sul campo che
consegnava ai pacchi di riso alla
popolazione affamata se vuoi il riso
lungo il riso non fa niente ti becchi
riso ecco adesso è cambiato un po questo
approccio non è molto apprezzato diciamo
nella cooperazione contemporanea e
soprattutto c'è bisogno di andare
incontro al beneficiario di fare in modo
che lui lei esprima le proprie necessità
è cambiata la società siamo nell'epoca
della connetto grafia quindi i confini
hanno lasciato spazio alle connessioni e
quindi abbiamo dei nuovi strumenti per
cambiare le cose non dobbiamo essere per
forza sul campo oggi possiamo cambiare
le cose dal divano di casa
spettatore della sofferenza che si
risveglia un attimo e cerca di fare
qualcosa allora cosa possiamo fare per
prima cosa dobbiamo
informarci si parte dall'inizio si parte
sempre dallo studio
è complesso richiede tempo dobbiamo
analizzare le fonti dobbiamo studiare
dobbiamo perderci tanto tempo però per
forza da lì dobbiamo partire per
analizzare un problema ovviamente non
sto parlando della aprire il link sulla
piattaforma digitale tempo di lettura
massimo stimato 4 minuti quello non è
informarsi culla e semplificare e ci
ricolleghiamo al discorso degli
stereotipi che non ci aiutano a
comprendere la realtà
discutere discutere con chi la pensa
diversamente da noi sempre in maniera
pacifica ovviamente noi non dobbiamo
discutere per ribattere dobbiamo
discutere per ascoltare per capire
dobbiamo capire per forza da dove
partire e non cambieremo il mondo in una
notte
però questo è il secondo passo che
possiamo fare
supportare supportare vuol dire non
creare delle nuove entità a meno che non
abbiamo delle idee geniali e
rivoluzionarie troviamo qualcuno che sta
già lottando per la casa nella quale
crediamo e supportiamo lo re non
dobbiamo creare concorrenza noi dobbiamo
unirci raggiungere un obiettivo ok
quindi troviamo l'organizzazione che ci
identifica e poi devolviamo tempo ed
energie per promuovere idee innovative e
rivoluzionarie
non aspettare perché in alcuni casi
aspettare vuol dire accettare ed è
sempre il momento giusto per fare la
cosa giusta quindi agiamo ora oggi
appena usciamo dal cinema ok e infine
ripetere ripetere ripetere ripetere che
è importante lottare per i diritti degli
altri ma è ancora più importante non
lottare contro i diritti degli altri
dobbiamo fregarsene dei diritti degli
altri ci deve interessare dei diritti
degli altri noi dobbiamo utilizzare il
nostro status di privilegiati per
favorire libertà e felicità a quante più
persone possibili quello status di
privilegiati non dobbiamo utilizzarlo
per ostacolare il cammino di chi cerca
di vivere una vita dignitosa
grazie
[Applauso]